TERRY ODA: What do you
really know about open source
projects?
SPEAKER 2: Have
you ever wondered
what it's like to
work on a project
with an organization like
Apache GNOME or KDE Eclipse
or hundreds more?
SPEAKER 3: Google Summer of
Code is a mentorship program
SPEAKER 2: That brings
programmers like you
WILLIAM CALDWELL: Together with
great mentors and awesome open
source projects.
TERRY ODA: You'll spend your
summer coding on a real world
project,
SPEAKER 3: Potentially
used by millions of people
all over the world.
SPEAKER 5: Mentors like
us will introduce you
to our diverse global community,
SPEAKER 6: Providing a
one-of-a-kind experience
and help you to succeed.
MATTHEW WELKS: As a
successful participant
in Google Summer of Code,
SPEAKER 8: You'll
receive a stipend
TERRY ODA: So you can focus
on your coding project.
SPEAKER 8: You'll
meet new people,
SPEAKER 9: Develop new skills,
SPEAKER 3: And
have a little fun.
MATTHEW WELKS:
I'm Matthew Welks.
SPEAKER 9: My name is Aaron.
SPEAKER 3: My name
is [? Condella ?]
SPEAKER 6: My name is Robert.
SPEAKER 10: My name
is [INAUDIBLE].
TERRY ODA: My name is Terry Oda.
SPEAKER 2: I'm
[INAUDIBLE] Gupta.
SPEAKER 5: My name
is [INAUDIBLE] Fisk.
SPEAKER 9: My name is
[? Avik ?] [INAUDIBLE].
SPEAKER 11: My name is Neha.
WILLIAM CALDWELL: My
name is William Caldwell
SPEAKER 2: We are Google
summer code mentors.
Go to g.co/gsoc to learn more.